hey everyone welcome to the brand-new
behind the screens the show where we
break down movie news and reviews
I'm your host a Strawson and today is
everything you need to know about
spider-man homecoming just say close to
the ground spider-man from you two let's
start with a quick recap of why they
rebooted spider-man again it all stems
from the Marvel Sony deal so before the
Marvel Cinematic Universe was even a
thing
Marvel license the rights of certain
characters to other studios to make
movies like x-men to Fox and spider-man
to Sony but then Marvel Studios had
Kevin Feige created the Marvel Cinematic
Universe making movies with characters
they still have the rights to like the
Avengers those movies as you may have
heard were a tad successful and put it
simply it's a bummer to not be able to
use major Marvel characters like
spider-man so in early 2015
Sony and Marvel struck a deal Sony will
make their own standalone spider-man
movies plus some of their own expanded
Spidey universe movies but spider-man is
part of the shared Marvel Cinematic
Universe and we'll hop on over to Marvel
sometime to fun here's the thing
Sony had recently rebooted spider-man
with Andrew Garfield so unfortunately
this meant scrapping the amazing
spider-man movies and starting over so
that spider-man made sense in the MCU
which brings us to our new Peter Parker
Tom Hollis now you don't need to know
much before seeing spider-man except one
thing you should absolutely see Captain
America Civil War to understand Peter
Parker's intro and his relationship with
Tony Stark aka Iron Man otherwise the
movie kind of seems to start out of
nowhere it might not make any sense plus
Civil War is referenced several times in
the movie and is truly integral to the
storyline you with me so far
okay now homecoming was teased by the
screenwriters John Francis daley and
Jonathan Goldstein early on as a John
Hughes type high school movie director
John watts a lot of jobs reiterated
those to me at Comic Con last year has
been described many times as like a John
Hughes Ian type so can you expand on
that a little bit
I mean just it's a it's a high-school
movie like I wanted to do something that
we have we've only seen little snippets
of in the past which is show what the
daily life of Peter Parker would be like
having this amazing secret having gone
through this incredible adventure in
civil war and then having to come back
to Queens and kind of make it back in
time for homecoming yeah so does this
approach work yes I had a giant smile
plastered across my face the entire
drive home from the theater this movie
has some of the most brilliantly clever
jokes I've ever seen in a superhero
movie here's an example of one that was
released online you can't just quit on a
stroll up and be welcomed back by
everyone hey welcome back Peter
flash you're back to first alternate
what what I mean and there was a
specific joke that happens in the
gymnasium that is so subtle that I kept
laughing about it over and over for the
next two days
to be honest I couldn't even really
think of a part of this movie that I
didn't like which is crazy because I
live to complain after the movie ended I
looked at the runtime because it feels
like you're sitting there for probably
45 minutes I could not believe that this
movie was over two hours long there was
zero wall people gave using the word fun
to describe this movie and I don't want
to sound like everyone else but it's
true it's fun it's fun it's fun it's fun
quick side note by the way it was
recently revealed that Tom Holland is
playing a young and Nathan Drake in a
live-action uncharted after seeing
spider-man I've completely changed my
mind about being angry about this
because Tom Hollands can do no wrong go
and see spider-man homecoming it's out
July 7th and come back on Saturday where
I'll be talking spoilers mystery
characters you should know and what
happens after those credits so like
comment subscribe and of course you can
tweet me your thoughts on the movie over
on Twitter thanks for watching
you
[Music]